- I just mentioned "City Slickers,"
which is one of my favorite movies.
I know it's a long time ago.
- That's never been mentioned
on anything I've ever,
like, "City Slickers,"
very rarely.
- Are you serious?
- Yeah, it's very rarely
talked about in the oeuvre,
you know what I mean?
(Kelly gasping)
(Jake chuckling)
- I thought I was gonna
be that annoying person
that asks you about the film
you're asked about all the time,
like, since you're a kid, okay.
- I mean kind of.
- And unique, okay.
- It's a very special movie for me,
'cause it's-
- Me too,
I love that movie so much.
- It's amazing, yeah.
- And I just thought it was so crazy.
So how did you end up doing that movie?
You were young, right?
- I was 11...
Yeah.
- Oh my gosh.
- I know, it's the first thing I ever did,
I was 11-years-old.
- Your first thing ever
to do was with that cast?
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] Sure.
- Pretty incredible, I know.
- Okay, okay.
(audience laughing)
- Well,
it's weird-
- Life.
(Jake laughing)
- It's like wow.
- Well, it's weird 'cause
my parents made movies
and, you know, my mother's a writer,
and so there was a night Billy Crystal
was actually at our house.
- What?
- And yeah, yeah.
And I was 10 or something like that,
and at the end of dinner
everyone was leaving,
and I was just so
enamored by him, you know,
like, I was like, oh my god, it's-
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I just picked up a chair
and I offered it to him as a parting gift.
(audience laughing)
I was like, here's a party favor.
I like handed him the gift,
and he thought it was so funny.
- 'Cause it's-
- And I was just wanting
to give him a chair.
- Just genuine, like, take this.
- I just didn't know what,
you know, when someone's like leaving
and you just want to give them something
and you're like, yeah,
just like, just take it
You know what I mean?
(Kelly laughing)
And that's how I was,
and he loved it.
- A souvenir of this dinner.
- (laughing) Basically.
And he was like, "That kid's
got something special."
(Kelly laughing)
(crowd laughing)
Little did he know, but yeah.
- Oh my god, that's amazing.
- He's like,
"Come audition for this
new movie that I'm doing,
'cause I need someone to play my son."
And then I did and then I got the part.
- [Kelly] That's so cool.
- Yeah.